تعرف انك تقود بشكل شخصي تحرك دولي لتطويق
جهود هذه الشركات كيف كانت ردود الفعل حتى
الان ما الذي فعلتموه
لقد كنت اناور مشروعي للالياف الضوئيه
وهو اول كابل ممول من القطاع الخاص لربط
قارات العالم باطول خط من بريطانيا حتى
اليابان بطولي نحو 18 الف كيلو متر كما
اشتغلت على كابلات اخرى عبر العالم
هل هناك اطراف اخرى يعني تشارك معك هل
هناك اطراف اتصلت بك هل هناك من تعاطى مع
الموضوع بشكل جدي
نعم بعض الحكومات تتحدث معي بشان اسلوب
التعامل مع قبضه شركه التكنولوجيا على
الكابلات البحريه لان هذا الموضوع خطير
جدا في كثير من الدول
هل هناك طريقه للتعامل مع هذا الوضع
الحساس يعني هل
ما الذي تخشاه اكثر من غيره
مثل ما قلت فانه عندما نرى مثل هذا الوضع
السياسي الغريب الذي يمر به العالم فانه
يتعين على كل دوله تتاكد من انها في حال
وجود اي ازمه فانها تحكم قبضتها فيما
يتعلق بالنفاذ الى الانترنت والاتصالات
عامه من وجهه نظري فانه من اولويات اي
حكومه الان ان تبدا بفرض التدخلها في
عمليه بناء الكابلات وفي الانترنت لضمان
انه مهما كان الوضع فان نفاذ مواطنها الى
الانترنت غير مهدد
[موسيقى]
هل لك ان تعطيني اسماء بعض الحكومات التي
تواصلت معك نعرف انه هذه السيطره حتى لو
كانت شركات خاصه الا انه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه رقم واحد التي تسيطر على هذه
الكيبلات بشركاتها الخاصه او بالاستثمارات
فيها اي حكومات اخرى تواصلت معك فيك
تعطينا اسماء
نعم مثال ذلك الحكومه الهنديه فقد اقتنعت
بان هذا الامر يمثل مشكلا لذلك بدات تطلب
وراء الخبراء ومنهم انا للنظر في كيفيه
تغيير البرامج الكبرى القائمه فيما يتعلق
بالكابليت هذه هي المره الاولى التي تعلن
فيها حكومه انها على وعي بالمشكل وتطلب
وراء الخبراء والناس بما يجعلها تضفي على
صناعه الكابلات بعدا سياسيا عبر اعتمادها
على الذات فيما يتعلق بالانترنت